I am very grateful to see that so many people gathered today
to celebrate together this Kagamibiraki of the Aikikai Hombu Dojo.
Last year, many events occurred in our society,
but thanks to everyone of you, Aikido could continue to evolve in the right direction.
Aikido has spread tremendously and it is now present in 130 countries.
I think that it is the pursuit of the dynamic created by the founder Morihei Ueshiba and continued by the second Doshu, Kisshomaru Ueshiba,
supported by your sincerity in practice, which has allowed the creation of such harmony.
I think that our duty is to keep this spirit in mind while training dutifully every day,
and in our own measure, contribute to the evolution of society by infusing it with the values carried by Aikido.
To do so, we must practice sincerely every day, and move forward while looking ahead.
Let's practice together in that spirit.
So are my wishes for 2015. Thank you all.